Some pharmacists wear lab coats.
Mayank Amin dons a different uniform.
Suited up as a superhero, he reaches into subzero storage for his vials of COVID-19 vaccines.
Amin owns the Skippack Pharmacy in Schwenksville, Pennsylvania,...
...a small community outside Philadelphia.
And on a recent March morning, he headed out to a gym, converted into a vaccine clinic,...
...to help protect lives in his community.
So, we received the COVID vaccine just about a month ago.
It's truly been a community effort.
Thanks to deep ties with their communities...
...and the trust they've been able to establish over the years,...
...small local pharmacies are instrumental in reaching people...
...who might be reluctant to get vaccinated...
...or may not know about vaccination efforts.
Amin has administered about 4,000 vaccine doses since February,...
...with help from one employee, two pharmacy interns and teams of volunteers...
...who help prep patients and paperwork.